okay so we'll just like dive into this
and and I'll start by saying you know
I've heard many successful founders
founders of later stage companies like
Dropbox Airbnb say that one of the most
important things that they spend their
time on as founders and as CEOs is
building and scaling good company
culture so culture is this really Nev
ulis concept and so I wanted to discuss
you know why it makes sense to think
about it at an early stage and how to
break this you nebulous concept into
more manageable kind of action items
that early stage founders can put into
place so last year I had about 50
conversations with founders of
early-stage companies and the people at
those companies who were building
culture and DNI initiatives and so I
wanted to introduce everyone here on the
podcast to two of the people that I
thought were the most thoughtful and had
done some incredible work in this space
and so I'll introduce you both so first
we have Claire McDonald she's the
founder of true link and true link makes
software it's tech enabled financial
services for older adults so Claire
you're at 35 employees now and they one
impressive thing is that they have a
woman or person of color who is leading
each of the the teams there and true
link has made some incredible progress
they had their customer base has grown
about 20x over the last three years and
I spent about an hour and an hour and a
half talking to Claire's team recently
and it was really clear to me that
Claire and her co-founder Kai were doing
some very intentional thinking about
culture and DNI a true link so thank you
for joining us thanks for having me very
happy to be here and next we have
Jennifer Kim and so Jennifer was one of
the very first employees at lever a
company that builds recruiting software
and and she built the DNI program at
lever and lever is about a hundred
employees 150 Oh about 150 and they're
at close to about 50/50 male/female
split in terms of the employees which
isn't easy it is not an easy feat in
Silicon Valley
and and so you know she is sort of one
of my mentors in a lot of this she's
authored a lot of incredible resources
for startups and founders who are
interested in learning about DNI and
culture and how to implement them in
really early-stage startups so thank you
for joining us yeah thanks for having me
so I thought let's just jump in so why
do you think there's so much attention
around culture nowadays in the press
among founders you know in blog posts
people are talking more and more about
culture than ever and I've always
thought it's been an important thing and
in you know 1992 for example there was a
study by HBS and the cotter Institute
that detailed the corporate cultures of
200 companies and they showed how good
culture affects everything from you know
long term economic performance
employment growth employment growth
revenue growth and companies focused on
culture outperformed by a huge amount so
why is this now being talked about more
commonly yeah I mean culture can be kind
of tricky to talk about right you ask
fish about water and the response that's
what's water so a culture is very much
how things are run it's everything
around you it's how your team sees it's
the lens for everything your team works
through so what's hard about culture
sometimes is that we kind of fall into
these two traps so often we're talking
about you know it's really visible and
tangible or what's really kind of like
stream negatives it's on the tangible
front you know the common misconception
is that oh you know we have a great
culture because of this ping-pong table
or happy hours which is great but it's
actually a very very small part of it
your culture is all about how you hire
what kind of conversations what's the
energy of the room how do you make
decisions who gets promoted right it's
not always so visible so it can be a
little bit tricky to talk about but and
therefore you know hard to manage and
sometimes even hard to measure but it
doesn't mean that some not important and
then on the second end you have if
you're watching the news day these days
there's a lot of attention on uber oh my
gosh how many articles have we all read
about uber and that's the kind of a
negative example but
you know there are so many great
companies out there really kind of
quietly toiling away working on culture
being really intentional but it wouldn't
be a very clique worthy headline you
know employees are generally civil to
each other and pretty happy with what
they have in terms of culture so it's
really easy to get intimidated and like
oh gosh like what are we supposed to do
there's so much we don't want to be the
next uber but it's just like any other
skill right if you're a founder if
you're growing a team you know even if
you started as to say an engineer hacker
you're probably having to get good at
sales and marketing and culture and
being a culture leader is one of them
yeah
so Clara question for you I'm when did
true Ling start the company yes so we
started back in late 2012 early 2013 so
how has the conversation even internally
it truly changed about culture and DNI
is it something you thought of since the
very beginning or has it sort of
increased as you've grown we've thought
about culture from the very beginning
and especially about building an
inclusive culture but it seems like we
think about it almost more every single
day because we see the payoffs of having
invested in it every single day and I
think the lesson we've learned over this
time over the last five years now since
we started back in 2013 late 2012 is
that the way you build your culture is
by small investments every single day
and that rather than being a distraction
from the business of running your
company and from the sort of constant
existential threat that you're under as
a start-up the investing in your culture
actually insulates you against that
threat right so being part of a team
that trusts each other where everyone
believes they're being treated fairly
and they're all in it together that's
actually how you survive not how you
distract yourself from survival I sort
of wanted to piggyback off what you were
just saying about what are some of the
benefits of intentionally focusing on
your culture early on like what are some
of the things that you've both seen from
your work well for me the privilege of
being a founder or an early employee is
that you actually get to create a
new little world a new community a new
environment and so the benefit of
creating that world in a way that
doesn't necessarily replicate the
dysfunction of the world outside the
office doors is that you get to be a
part of it so I actually like going to
work every day i feel respected and
valued i think most members of our team
feel respected and valued or we
certainly try to make it that way and
that's really great and really pleasant
actually
that was one of the things that struck
me from talking to your team they were
all very they were very mission driven
they said they you know felt respected
every person I talked to had could you
know repeat to me what the mission of
the company was and what their role was
in making that happen and they were they
it felt like a very unified team and the
thing that kept coming up over and over
again was respect they said that they
focus on hiring people that respect each
other respect the elderly they were you
know they they respect was something
that came up multiple times in my
conversations with everyone and so I
thought that was a really interesting
thing it's like the respect was like the
major theme of the conversation for us
related to that at lever we've seen huge
benefits in terms of both recruiting and
retention so recruiting for example we
had a one QA engineer who was hired
because her friend was also interviewing
for that role and he was actually under
qualified he was grape just a little bit
under qualified was turned down but he
loved going through the process so much
and he kind of fell in love with a
little bit of levers culture so when he
got turned down he actually told his
friend hey you should apply and she had
more experience and she was fantastic so
I think it's really going to be a
competitive advantage right like imagine
every person that comes across you know
applying with their resume or you ever
interview them they become an advocate
for you like what a powerful recruiting
force that can be on the retention side
you know for a long time at lever we had
such low attrition rates because people
feel connected to the work and the
people
and you know feel proud of where they
work like Claire does Sutton I think you
know our salespeople and engineers are
all great I mean they're getting weekly
recruiter reach outs you know promising
them but we'll give you so much more
equity and here's like how much more we
can paint you and there's always going
to be companies trying to poach away
your best employees but again they stay
because they want to because they feel
connected to of the culture one engineer
who's been there three years his name is
Xia's he told me once you know technical
problems the really cool ones will come
and go there will always be new cool
thing to work on but he stays because
really finding that right team and
environment like that's truly the rare
thing in Silicon Valley I think that's
that's absolutely correct is that in
hiring the best people and retaining
them I think culture is the biggest kind
of you know tool that you have in the
tool kit for that because there are so
many companies recruiting is so hard I
mean you've both you know been on that
side of things and and to have you know
people be connected to the team and to
the mission I think is a great piece of
it that's sort of the business case for
an inclusive culture right in addition
to inclusive culture making a company a
great place to be every day
fundamentally I'm especially at early
stages you have to create an environment
where you're all your employees and your
most valuable employees that have your
institutional knowledge want to keep
coming back to work every day want to
ignore the emails from recruiters and
want to choose your company again every
day and an inclusive culture where
people are treated fairly I think is
really the only way to make that happen
yeah I feel like for a long time culture
was kind of seen as a luxury right we
need to focus on growth first and we'll
kind of like worry about that later when
we're much bigger you know when it's not
my problem anymore but that's just not
gonna fly and because there is now so
much attention on this even externally I
think it's it's popping up in founders
minds much sooner than maybe it once was
perhaps so these are really great
examples of you know when you're doing
culture right these are the some of the
things either these are some of the
benefits these are some of the things
that you do well but as you were saying
at the
beginning of a start-ups life every day
is a fight for survival so you know what
happens if you don't think about it
until later what are some of the risks
there well I think here's the thing to
keep in mind even if you do think about
it all the time as I think one of our
team members told you some members of
our team
think about it obsessively you still
make mistakes all the time right so
we're we think about this we invest in
this and we're really far from perfect
so as I'm thinking about all we've
accomplished also running through my
mind are all the mistakes and screw-ups
that we've made right and how you know I
feel like the thing we're proud of is
how much we care and how we're making
progress every day but nobody's perfect
so if you're not investing and trying to
not make mistakes you're probably making
even more of them yeah that's a really
good point because you know especially
for folks who haven't thought a whole
lot about culture or diversity and
inclusion initiatives they might think
like well like you know that's not my
background that's not what I'm good at
but it is such a critical part in that
you know it's not as hard as you think
to get started right if you're looking
at you know for example Airbnb like oh
my gosh look at all the culture
initiatives they have like well they're
so much bigger than you and they've been
going at it for a long time so I think
really lowering the Stace and kind of
seeing it as a muscle to develop and
practice and yeah it really helps to do
it from the beginning so that you build
good habits as an organization I think
the key to remember is that yeah no one
is perfect I don't know if anyone's born
a amazing culture leader I think as long
as you are authentic with your
intentions and you're open and you're
really bring in conversations and
approach it as a team activity no one
person's in charge of culture you can
really do a lot together so let's kind
of dig into let's get even more specific
and start digging a little bit into
tactics because you know as we're
talking about how do we make this a
muscle that we can sort of exercise it
and make stronger so you know from day
one what are some of the things that you
recomended founders do even when it's
just two people in a room so for me the
Achilles heel of an inclusive culture is
unchecked biases so it's letting all the
cognitive biases in our head run rampant
without checking them ourselves or
creating ways for our colleagues to
check them so we've introduced a variety
of small things that help us check
ourselves and check each other that I
think make a huge difference in culture
and are actually really easy to do so
like what are some examples let's just
leave it at that
a big theme for for checking biases for
us is credit and blame so there's a lot
of research that shows that women and
people of color get less credit for
their accomplishments and get blamed
more or sort of it's the things they
screw up are remembered more okay so
what do you do about that so we do a few
things culturally so one thing is we
doesn't how I remember it it's not what
we actually call it but I think of it as
no blame button so in github you can
click a button that basically shows you
where the sort of like offending code is
that caused a problem right which is
actually an extremely useful feature so
no hate on the blame button but we try
not to have a cultural blame button
right so when there's a mistake or a
screw-up what we collectively try to do
and anybody who's available tries to do
is solve the problem not focus on
blaming someone for it then only once
we've solved the problem and put things
in place to make sure the same thing
doesn't happen again do we reflect about
how that happened and collectively
working to make sure that doesn't happen
again otherwise I think you can sort of
fall into patterns of scapegoating and
blaming people and holding things
against people really easily and if you
have that as a part of your culture it's
almost inevitable that some people are
going to be targeted more than others
yeah that's really great because yeah
like you said there's all these patterns
plus the more it happens less people
will be to take risks right because if
you want to be blamed so it sounds like
you're really setting up an environment
where people can try things out and you
don't have to have it all figure it out
but you're more likely to get big wins
out of that too and the other side of
not
no blame button is actually making sure
people get credit and amplifying credit
where it's due so this was a story that
there was a story that came out of the
Obama White House that reminded me of
kind of how we've approached this a true
link imperfectly but we try which was
incorrect me if I get the details wrong
in the first year of the Obama
administration some of the women who
worked there noticed that they and other
women weren't getting credit for their
ideas in meetings so they started using
a great strategy amplification which is
when cat says something in a meeting
instead of saying that's a great idea
I say cat's idea to X is a great idea
just to make sure that everyone here is
that it was cat who said it so we try to
do things like that we also try to make
basically acknowledgments and shouting
out to people for the good work that
they do an important part of our culture
in an ongoing way so it's the most
popular section of all company meetings
where you have a big wide open period of
time where people are basically telling
people about the good work that other
people have done and I think this is
especially important across teams right
so people on the engineering team are
hearing about the specific
accomplishments of members of the
marketing team the support team and vice
versa one thing that I wanted to ask you
specifically was when I talked to your
team there was a sense that everyone
felt really appreciated so they said you
know we're building an environment where
the ops team is as respected and
celebrated as the engineering team and
when you talk to a lot of companies
especially in Silicon Valley there's a
sense that you know software engineering
is the you know the golden egg everyone
you know is excited about the engineers
and Ops kind of gets left behind and so
how did you how do you do that how do
you create a culture where both where
all people feel as celebrated well it's
definitely an uphill battle in Silicon
Valley so this particular she was sort
of a bee in my bonnet and a bee and my
co-founder kaya's bonnet as well and let
me tell you why and tell me if this sort
of theory makes sense to you all so I
think that prizing certain teams at
companies so it used to be sales teams
now it's engineering teams is I think
prising certain teams is actually a
coded way of prising sir
races and genders so I think we all know
that in most companies the majority of
engineering team are men for example and
mad props to you if that's not the case
in your company and you can just stop
listening but so when you actually treat
that class of employees differently than
you treat everyone else and I'm not
talking about kind of keeping up with
market compensation I'm talking about
the way you talk to people the perks
people get and the way the way
leadership focuses on one team versus
the other when you treat teams
differently in that way I think what
you're actually doing is perpetuating
society-wide biases about race gender
ethnicity and things like that so I
think unless you've achieved perfect
diversity and your engineering team is a
mirror of our society a balance of
gender and race and ethnicity and age
across teams that mirror each other and
the mirror society at large if you were
prizing your engineering team over
everyone else you are perpetuating
biases and discriminating against folks
so breaking that down a little bit how
do you make sure that the ops team other
teams don't feel like they're less
important so here's the tricky part is
part of this is that we authentically
believe that they are not less important
so we have 99 percent customer
satisfaction ratings from our support
team we have the highest Net Promoter
Score I've ever seen in financial
services that's not because of the
engineering team and our amazing
products that's because of all the teams
of the company and all the people and
the wonderful talented people who lead
those teams and who we've retained for
multiple years because we value them so
so specifically so we believe it that's
one thing and I think actually it's
worth founders looking in the mirror and
seeing and asking themselves do I
believe this do I equally value all
these teams do I see how they contribute
to the company and then once you answer
that question for yourself it becomes
easier to in team meetings to talk about
that to acknowledge the different roles
of different team members we also do
sort of trainings and sessions at our
team retreats to help people understand
the contributions of other teams so at
our last retreat we did a
Marketing 101 and a financial advising
101 so people could really understand
tactically what those teams do and how
technical and complex and challenging it
is we also do what we call ride-alongs
with our support team so engineers and
other team members actually sit with the
support team and listen to them engaging
with folks and after two hours of
sitting with a member of our support
team you cannot help but be awed and
respected by what they do another thing
we do is when people join the company we
make sure they have coffees and lunches
with people from all different teams of
the company so that people really get to
know each other and kind of have human
relationships and respect each other as
humans in addition to their roles at the
company so those are some of the things
we do some similar things too with both
onboarding and I'm kind of ongoing so
that a cross-functional exposure can be
so important so for example people used
to come in to levar as new hires saying
oh you know I've heard such great things
about the product it's really awesome
it must sell itself right so as part of
our onboarding we actually have every
new hire every onboarding class watch
what a real sales call looks like and
then do a Q&A with a sales rep because
that notion gets thrown out the window
you know you hear how stressful it can
be the questions that get thrown at you
the frustration sometimes the sales rep
has to really navigate through but still
calm top of the game and really push
that deal forward and then the Q&A is
fascinating because every time it's like
wow like that was like you know my blood
was boiling listening to that call like
how do you handle that kind of question
and that and over time really builds
like a respect for the other function
right so this room of like you know not
to pick on engineers but like I'm an
engineer so I'm better like there's just
no room for it because you understand
how hard those jobs are and how it's a
good self-reflection exercise for like
man if I were in that role I would
probably suck at that job and really
realizing all of us here for a reason we
have a role to play to make the entire
business successful I love that sales
idea I'm gonna start doing that also and
that reminds me of another one of our
approaches to this challenge which is
our no jerks policy so in
we have a very firm no jerks policy and
every time we violated that it's been a
really big mistake how do you know what
someone's a jerk yes good question so
one we put it on our job description so
we hope that helps screen people out but
also we're basically looking for
humility in respect in the hiring
process so we do this for in a few
different ways we focus on times people
have gotten feedback asking them to tell
us about that and how they responded to
that how they changed their behavior we
have people interact with members of a
lot of different teams on different
levels and we evaluate how they treat
everyone basically that's a really big
one and then we also discussed diversity
and inclusion in our culture we talked
about our value of humility and
respecting different functions things
like that so from across those things it
actually becomes pretty clear pretty
quickly and I think that's a big factor
in why our team is composed of actually
all the wonderful people that it is
adding on to you know yeah hiring for it
the no jerks policy really the watching
how candidates interact with different
levels of people can be so key so two
examples of this our receptionists are
told if for any reason anyone any
candidate makes you feel disrespected or
they're any comments like let us know
right away so it was either me you know
or let the recruiter know because the
person who was a little bit rude to the
receptionist you know but comes across a
super suave and confident with everybody
else that might be a flag of course it's
not going to be the you know automatic
video power but it's just one data point
of many you're collecting in a hiring
process another example I have with this
ism we were hiring for a PM product
manager and there was this person with
the perfect resume you know all the
right schools and companies and they
just were so confident that everybody
was you know in love with this candidate
and it looked like a pretty you know
full full speed ahead for his hiring and
when we were doing one of the hiring
debriefs one of our most junior members
of the product team kind of hesitant
hesitantly raised his hand and said hey
like I don't really know how to say this
I had some weird interactions with him
so it turned out during that
conversation he so there were three
people in the room and the most junior
member felt like this candidate wasn't
ever addressing him so would not make
eye contact would kind of talk over him
only answer questions and ask questions
of the more senior p.m. that was in the
room so he was saying and he feels so
bad bringing it up because he wasn't
sure it was appropriate but once he said
it it kind of made us realized actually
he is a little bit comes across as
arrogant right so really that
distinction of someone who interviews
really well versus when someone kind of
gives indicators of who they are kind of
like as a co-worker it can be like a
such a huge wake-up call because once
we're looking at that candidate with
that lens we started kind of remembering
like oh yeah there was that one little
weird moment or he did say this and this
email kind of rubbed me the wrong way
but we'd kind of gotten dazzled by their
resume which happens all the time so I
think assembling interview panels across
multiple levels can be really really
helpful we do something really similar
and actually a really helpful tool for
us in making our interview panels even
more effective and really pulling out
feedback from people has been lever and
using the feedback forms on lever
actually before we even get together as
a group to discuss things so that
everyone feels like they have no-one's
influenced by other people's view and
everyone sort of forced in a discipline
way to talk about the pros and cons of a
candidate and levers been really helpful
for us in surfacing some of that and
even for me personally I am sensitive to
those cues right when someone's making
eye contact with my co-founder and not
me and it's always a delicate balance of
saying am I being oversensitive or is
this a real thing and I think actually
taking that moment to reflect in front
of the computer and collect the data and
then compare that data to what other
people submitted has just been
invaluable for us so another thing that
I think is really important is you've
talked about feedback channels
making it possible for you know everyone
to give each other feedback and then
also having hard conversations and you
know feedback can be difficult to give
and so how do you build it into your
cultures so that you can have these
really kind of uncomfortable
conversations and make it okay so I
think this is an ongoing challenge and I
actually think it's something that's
really easy to get complacent about as
either a founder or a leader or a
manager or you say I'm getting tons of
feedback give me feedback they feel
comfortable right and so I think it's
actually really important to always be
saying is that true is that happening
and I think one of the most valuable
tools for this has been a couple things
one we do diversity and inclusion
trainings that are actually a lot about
speaking out and how to speak out if
there's something that makes you
uncomfortable and I think we actually
are gonna go even deeper on that because
it can put people in a tough position to
know like how do I bring this up
respectfully and with whom to I think is
modeling so you talk to a couple of our
team members who cared a lot about
diversity inclusion Paige and Isaac and
I think they model for the whole team
actually bringing up issues with folks
in a really respectful way raising
issues with me and KY sometimes in front
of the whole team in a team meeting
saying you know hey did you mean to say
that that way and and I think it's that
modeling that shows like we actually all
have an open conversation this isn't
about hierarchy it's about respect that
is maybe one of the most powerful tools
I think a little bit of investment into
communication and almost emotional
intelligence 101 can go a really really
long way so what you might take for
granted when you're again five ten
people those when you are now hundred
and two hundred and you don't have as
close relationships just investing a
little bit and injecting into kind of
that emotional intelligence student your
culture can have such multiplier effects
so two things that we've done one
there's this concept called nonviolent
communications amazing tool terrible
name nonviolent communications what does
that mean so another alternative name
for that it's called compassionate
communication it's
style and kind of a practice of
communication that is rooted in empathy
and about self-expression and about
these human emotional needs that we all
have but sometimes in the fast-paced
business setting it can kind of get
glossed over which makes
misunderstanding or judgment a lot more
likely so we've run a couple of
workshops on that another one that's
been really helpful for us is a one
called colors there's a ton of these
kind of like personality assessments out
there and all have their pros and cons
but what we liked about colors is that
it helps give people a framework for
individual differences and kind of
stylistic communication differences why
someone is really you know why someone
might be really drawn to this kind of
project whereas I get motivated by this
which is different than this so when you
join lever you take this you know short
test and it tells you what color energy
from this you know rainbow circle you're
leading with and kind of what you are
drawn to and what your strengths are it
gives us people this basic framework for
understanding yourself and then
therefore once you become a more
confident understanding yourself you
become a lot more tolerant of other's
differences piggybacking off of the idea
of you know modeling I have seen that it
does make a huge difference when the
founders of the exact team are really
honest and open about you know the
mistakes they've made because this is
you know tricky territory culture and
DNI and all these conversations are
really tough to have and so I think it's
it's always great when you know founders
can be open with their team about
mistakes and and that makes I think a
lot of people feel more open about
sharing their own or realizing that a
lot of mistakes aren't intentional um so
in in that sort of frame of mind I'll
share a mistake that that I've made here
at YC and then if you know you know not
all this stuff as you said Claire you're
not perfect you know you don't have the
you know the silver bullet you don't
have no company has all the answers so I
think for me one of the mistakes I made
is at YC
we run the female founders conference
and we are in our fifth year you know
it's a conference we're over a thousand
women come and we made it about three or
four years and realized we never had a
mother's room so this is a thousand
women and we didn't have any
accommodations for women who had just
given birth who needed to take time in a
private setting to pump their breast
milk and and for me I you know don't
have children and I don't have that
experience it didn't even occur to me
that was just something you even needed
and so you know one of the attendees
reached out and pointed it out and said
you know it's something that she would
have very much appreciated it was super
distracting for her to sort of run
around the building looking for a place
to go and it just made me realize that
without a diversity of perspectives and
experiences on the team you know you
just miss out on a lot of different
things that you need to make you know to
start building in a culture that
includes all kinds of people and so I
would love to hear story do you have a
specific story where you know a mistake
that you've made something that you wish
you could get a do-over on you know
something that you know you hope others
will learn from I think another blind
spot for me and for a lot of early-stage
founders is the fact that you actually
you have to play a lot of different
roles at the company right so for
example I've always taken care of the HR
function right so in addition to being
people's supervisor in terms of their
work performance I'm also the first
thing they have to come talk to you
about a benefits issue right or a family
issue and I think that actually puts
people in a pretty hard situation and
and seems actually like an intractable
challenge right if you're like well it's
a five person team who else are they
going to talk to but what I've realized
recently is that it's as simple as
saying hey if you have questions about
this or issues about this here's two to
four other people you can talk to right
it doesn't have to be me
or like if you have a problem with me
here are some other members of the team
that you can talk to and we're lucky to
have this strong set of leaders right
but it's literally as simple as saying
one sentence and it basically makes the
problem go away
when you're running a startup things are
moving so quickly things are changing
constantly you really underestimate how
confusing it might be if you're a person
that's joining for the first time and
you're trying to figure out your job and
everything culture around it right so I
found yeah really writing things down
really investing in again onboarding has
gone such a long way well you don't want
to happen and that's all the mistakes
that we've made not making some of the
expectations clearer so people feel like
they have to guess or they're wondering
they're sitting there I mean like am I
doing this right and leaving you know
sometimes losing good candidate or good
employees because they were like look
like I need a little bit more explicit
guidance and realizing wow we could have
done just a little bit more to make
their confusion really elevated right so
when you're running a company it's hard
but just a little bit of investment into
writing things down explicit
communication goes such a far away I
completely agree I think I've learned
that lesson over and over again and it
still might not have fully sunk in but
it's so true right of saying hey I think
we have an implicit policy about this
thing maybe if I took 45 minutes and
wrote that down and put it on our
internal wiki I wouldn't answer 30
questions about it over the course of
six months right where it's this this
little upfront investment that actually
saves a lot of time and confusion and if
I'm getting 30 questions that means that
was 30 employees who were actually
probably thinking about it and tried to
find the answer and wasted a bunch of
time before they came to me or other
folks with the question and once that's
written down then you can't invite more
discussion and questions I help me make
it better right but if it's in your head
no one can figure it out so we're all
just kind of trying to figure out what
you mean so writing things down you know
investing in an intranet where you write
down policies over communicating during
during your whatever weekly or bi-weekly
all-hands can be really helpful so I
wanted to go over some of your favorite
resources so founders want to learn more
about culture and we didn't even get to
dig into D&I much at all but if they
wanted to start reading on it what are
some of the you know your favorite
pieces that you might recommend and you
know I I would say one of the things
that I loved reading is Jennifer wrote a
piece that was called 50 ideas for
workplace DNI that you can start today
and we can link to it in our blog but I
think it's a four it's you know sort of
a primer or you know it's 50 you know
easy things that you can implement to
you know at an early stage company and
so that you know to start things off is
one of the things that I would recommend
and folks take a look at the three
resources I would recommend are first of
all Facebook has an an online training
called managing bias that's basically
about well managing bias so it's an
inclusion training and one of our team
members Isaac has adapted that training
for the company and given it in a few
different ways and it's great resources
and it will it makes preparing a
training about a very complex topic much
faster and easier or you could just do
it yourself it's really interesting and
edifying and all online another place
where we've gotten a lot of resources
focused on inclusion in particular is
caper capitals founders commitment so
the founders commitment is a pledge that
early-stage startups take to commit to
taking small but meaningful actions that
relate to diversity and inclusion a lot
of incredible companies are a part of it
and they've put together a ton of great
resources that make it easier to make
simple easy moves on a lot of this stuff
so I really recommend checking that out
and considering joining and then finally
I love first round review they have a
lot of incredible pieces on culture and
inclusion written by people who have
accomplished really impressive things on
these fronts so there's probably like 15
different pieces on there that have been
really helpful for me yeah I would agree
loll so all those I'd probably add on
one more project include project include
org is an organization a non-profit
founded by a bunch of really amazing
women with years of experience in
Silicon Valley they've seen it all so
they came together to put together these
recommendations ranging from hiring to
culture to measuring everything that you
want to do to follow to make sure you're
building
right scaffolding the right foundation
to build the right culture from the very
early days so I recommend to every
founder that they least read for at once
because you're gonna learn so much from
it awesome is there anything else that
you guys wanted to hit on so one other
thing that is is challenging but
important from an inclusivity
perspective is um well it's basically
just like interruptions
and interrupting in meetings and how
that like perpetuates power dynamics
basically I find this really hard
because I'm a huge interrupter maybe
maybe I should constantly be recording
and have microphones in front of my face
but I think that when I think there's
some simple ways to reduce people
interrupting each other in meetings
right so you can like assign somebody
for each meeting as the interruption
police whose job is stopping that you
can just remind people with one sentence
on the wall but if you if you want a
quick and easy way to not replicate bias
and weird power dynamics slowing down
interruptions at your company is a good
way to do that if you're any kind of
team leader really understanding DNI is
all about paying attention to those
people who are more perceptive and more
effective than the average person by
some of the systemic inequalities and
obstacles so if anything they're just
trying to give you information and
better signal so here's what we should
work on together because if you ship the
right programs and make the right
improvements it's only going to end up
helping your entire company but it's
gonna benefit everyone staying goes you
know rising tide lifts all boats so I
really think that's what sustainable
culture building and DNI is all about
it's not us versus you it's not you get
this and I get that it really is about
how do we just build better companies
and we'll all benefit from that my last
question for both of you is going to be
you know what's one thing that you would
recommend founders and team builders do
you know if they want to start thinking
intentionally about culture and D&I from
day one you know I think there's an
infinite number of initiatives and
programs you can google them
you have plenty of ideas to get started
I think one thing we're not talking
about nearly as much is you know this
conversation around how do you learn to
become a better culture leader right so
I can kind of give like one ongoing
thing in one short-term thing so what I
really love about you know YC is really
great about giving this advice and
really drilling it down to the founders
take care of yourself get sleep exercise
make sure you should make sure you're
taking breaks spend time with friends
and family I think this is really
important because even though there's
all this pressure around you know crazy
growth and 10x in yourself at the same
time it's nearly impossible to be a
really great culture leader if you're
burnt out if you don't if you're running
on fumes because to really build culture
in a thoughtful way you need to kind of
embody the spirit of almost generosity
and deep caring for your people right
like clear I know you're doing that
because the things that your employees
are saying they wouldn't be saying it if
you didn't really deeply care for your
team and they didn't know it you know
what I mean so really remembering that
if you want to build a great culture
start with yourself right making sure
make sure you're taken care of
you can't do the job without you being
ok and then maybe a little bit more a
short-term thing you know I can DNI and
culture it can sometimes be like oh
that's not my thing that's not my area
of expertise why not right like culture
is everyone's business
especially if you're part of any team
and it's doubly especially if you're any
kind of leader right so I really
encourage everyone to think about what
can I do to really show everyone that
I'm learning about this and I care about
it and encourage others to care about it
too right maybe sure this podcast was
your team or a blog post that you really
like
I'm sure it on Twitter it'll be a good
break from all the crypto you're
tweeting about I think a really good way
to do is is you know share something
just a couple sentences on like here's
what I've learned and invite others to
what did you learn what did you agree
with what resonated maybe what do you
think we should start doing I think it's
a really great invitation for a
conversation about culture and showing
that
I'm learning and I want you to learn
with me we're gonna do this together so
my two pieces of advice are 1 figure out
why you care about this and what you
care about
specifically right so what motivates you
when it comes to inclusion what
motivates you when it comes to culture
and the second piece and this is really
building on what Jen was saying is
empowering members of your team so at
true link it's actually members of our
team who aren't me and CAI I've
mentioned a couple of them this podcast
Isaac and Paige and other people who I
think are some of the real leaders at
the company around building an inclusive
culture and that's happened because
they're empowered to be leaders at the
company because we've talked about it
because we share values and so I think
it's really sort of like having those
conversations and opening it up so other
people can be leaders and that's
especially helpful when you are burnt
out and tired and not taking care of
yourself and you're not really at your
best like it's cool to know that I can
rely on other folks to play that
leadership role and to build the culture
we want even when I'm not having my most
energetic day or my priority list is so
long I can't get to those things that I
wanted to focus on and that's great and
I think it has to come from the founders
like the founders have to empower you
know other people to do that I mean
it'll come from them but then also give
people the autonomy and the power to you
know take that role and that's something
I think that was beautiful about what
you know lever did and what you did
there is that you know you really owned
that piece as lever grew yeah I really
feel like I was given this really great
opportunity from the liver founders like
hey run with it go with it and what
started as it's like a very tiny kind of
a couple of in person conversations grew
into this large brand and a number of
initiatives and lever really becoming
known as well the companies that's
embracing DNI right when I started at
almost four years ago I would have I
could have never predicted and this is
how it's going to turn out but when you
know like Clara said founders are
authentic about why they care and they
empower others to do it it can have this
like really magical multiple
creative effect very cool well thank you
guys thank you thank you Kat yeah